damn Kim that's Kanye and we're gonna be
doing our design quiz Kim and Kanye's
house is like no other and now we are
able to step inside like never before
and get an even closer look into their
otherworldly sixty million dollar
mansion but he ain't gonna put his feet
on our council tell you that the
couple's home which they helped design
is the cover star of Architectural
Digest March star power issue and lucky
for us they have opened up the doors to
what Calle calls quote their futuristic
Belgian monastery it's a quiz each other
on home design family and life if our
house had a soundtrack what would it be
and why I mean I think Jesus is king
because that's just the verb right now
and that's the soundtrack right now yeah
hallelujah hallelujah yeah the kids love
singing that they talked about
everything from choosing their home to
its extensive renovation to their
favorite rooms the bathroom is one of my
favorite rooms also because of the way
it's the one that's most similar to the
concept of our houses in the future even
though it's square and the other house
they're more organic but I love how the
whole side of the bathroom is just blown
out and that was Chris I did she was
like you guys need a bigger back and I
was like oh a bathroom and then it's
like we had that huge bathroom that
pushed our project back by like eight
months we had just continued to live
with my mom for like eight months thanks
a lot Chris thanks a lot mom Kim even
dished on which room has the best
lighting for selfies she's like oh that
was the first thing I excited ooh
finally I would honestly say the theater
because I like a dark room and I like to
use a flash fun fact
we also learned something about Kim that
Kanye didn't even know was the last time
you used a pool I've never used our pool
actually what yeah can you believe that
but I love our pool one of the best
parts about watching the quiz is that
you really get to see Kim and Kanye's
chemistry
take the spotlight what is the most
prized possession in the house yeah I
was gonna say that
I do it again and then save me
North stole our hearts when she crashed
the interview letting us know her
favorite things to do in the house
jams competitions in the hallways in the
summer you love to swim Kim and Kanye's
home is just one example of how Kanye is
broadening his skills when it comes to
design in 2018 can share with eats he
that Kanye's growing love for
architecture has the couple traveling
the world we went on an architecture
trip he loves architecture so we went to
go meet with some Japanese architects
and see some James Terrell exhibits in a
museum on an island off of Japan so it
was really amazing
[Music]